avec miam rlr de maisons laffitte
bonsoir jacques myard merci d'être avec
nous la précommande de renaud muselier
de scouts vous devez elle est justifiée
selon vous il a il a raison de ne pas
attendre en tout cas il va attendre
avant de l'utiliser mais de d'anticiper
les choses renaud muselier et écoutez
c'est assez simple parce que toutes vos
épisodes et tout ce que vous venez dire
ça s'appelle à la recherche du temps
perdu et on pourrait envoyer cet ouvrage
de proust au président de la république
et aussi à la commission de bruxelles
donc c'est trop cher du temps perdu sa
rattrapable renaud muselier que je
connais bien qui est médecin a
parfaitement raison de commander des
doses de spots nique tout en devant
attendre la mise l'autorisation de
l'agencé européenne des médicaments
puisqu'ils ne pourrait pas le faire
sinon il encourt s'il y avait quelques
problèmes des condamnations et des
procédures judiciaires
mais en réalité il faut regarder les
choses telles qu'elles sont il est exact
que appelé initiaux il eût fallu
négocier massivement seule capitale
d'ailleurs ils ont payé et que l'europe
a voulu avoir le moindre prix ce qui est
une faute
dans une affaire comme cela c'est pas
une question de prix c'est une question
d'urgence
deuxièmement ce qui va arriver c'est
pour ça que il faut dire est de
constituer un français attention ce qui
va arriver
ce sont des doses importantes surtout de
seconde vaccination
donc parce que il y a des délais celles
et ceux qui auront été vaccinés
il y a au mois de mars vont être
vaccinés maintenant en avril et donc
dans ces conditions il ne faut pas
s'attendre à ce qu'il y ait à nouveau
des premières vaccinations et que les
gens vont piaf et surtout que le
gouvernement a décidé et là je crois
juste titre qu'il ne s'agissait pas de
passer par catégorie
socioprofessionnelle
à savoir par exemple les chauffeurs de
taxi des professeurs mais continuer sur
le même je dirais un différentiel d'âge
il ya eu des 75 ans les 70 ans mais non
les plus de 55 et donc on a encore
devant nous je dirais beaucoup de temps
à avoir et nous devons aider français
vont devront prendre leur mal en
patience
voilà la réalité parce que au début il
ya eu un ratage jacques myard justement
sur cette question du vexin rue st la
france insoumise le rassemblement
national
les républicains dont vous faites partie
la majorité commence à devenir très
isolé sur cette question puisqu'on voit
elle freine des quatre fers évidemment
nous a déjà prévenu qu on n'aurait pas
besoin de ce vaccin on voit bien que
c'est un souci pour eux de de l'accepter
comment expliquer cela soit en vous
alors écoutez il faut quand même
reconnaître que dès le début la france
en vrille et demie sur un scoop pour
vous garder ce qu'il en était et ça
c'est bien le land 7
vous le savez a déclaré dans une étude
que c'était l'un des meilleurs vaccins
et qu'il protégeait ensuite il ya un
problème de fabrication
et là je dirais nos amis russes doit
prendre en compte le fait que pour
livrer en europe
une fois que healy à l'autorisation de
l'agencé européenne des médicaments
il y à la fabrication hélas il semble
quand même que la fabrication de ce
vaccin ne permettent pas de livrer tous
les états mais jacques myard donnez moi
mais les russes auront sont prêtes ont
simplement ils l'ont dit hein
ils ne disent pas qu'ils sont capables
de fournir inondé toute l'europe des de
leurs vaccins mais il se propose
justement de le fabriquer en
collaboration et c'est ce que soient les
allemands et les italiens pourquoi pas
les français alors capté d'accord et je
trouve que c'est une excellente solution
mais il n'en demeure pas moins que pour
fabriquer sa en commun et préparer les
usines où on va oui va ya voir l'arrivée
de la méthode du vaccin
sa fabrication ça se fait pas en quinze
jours pour regarder les choses telles
qu'elles sont vous savez il faut quand
même savoir que aujourd'hui l'humanité
avec un avantage réussi à mettre au
point des vaccins en un temps record par
rapport à ce qu'ils étaient je dirais
les méthodes antérieures donc il est
clair que c'est une très bonne nouvelle
que les russes proposent que le
gouvernement russe propose que l'on
puisse fabriquer en europe des vaccins
spoutnik
il n'en demeure pas moins qu'il faut que
les usines qui vont devoir le faire
puissent s'adapter et ça ne se fait pas
en claquant des doigts
donc je pense qu'on est sur la bonne
voie je me félicite de l'offre multiple
de vaccins même si certains donnent font
peur à nos concitoyens à s'entraîner
qu'a
parce que ça c'est un problème réel même
si 30 millions de britanniques ont été
vaccinés avec astra zeneca il est clair
que les vaccins arrivent et que la mise
en oeuvre
c'est toujours la même chose prenons un
peu de temps jacques myard pardonnez moi
mais ça pose un réel problème on est en
train de jeter des doses que veut la
défiance le danemark a annoncé qu'il
arrêtait astrazeneca l'europe d'ailleurs
ne reconduira pas le contrat l'année
prochaine elle l'a déjà annoncé mais
nous on continue tout de même idem pour
johnson and johnson pour l'instant une
pause aux états unis après des
thromboses ça donne un sentiment qui
n'est pas très encourageant aux nombreux
c'est plus de france est un
tout de même je savais il est évident
que vous avez toute une série de nos
concitoyens je connais autour de moi qui
vont refuser la salle seneca tout
simplement parce que ils se disent
certes les cas de thrombose sont rares
ça tombe sur moi ça sera trop tard donc
il est évident que ça pose ce problème
là ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui c'est
quand même la multiplication des
possibilités si je mets à part
astrazeneca sur l'arrivée de nouveaux
vaccins y compris de ce pique nique
donc je suis assez confiant mais on
n'est pas sorti du tunnel
il faut le savoir et c'est une mise en
leur savez il faut bien comprendre une
chose c'est que on a oublié que ce
vaccin que ce virus allait durer on est
vous savez on a oublié que la grippe
espagnole en 1919
elle a duré plus de deux ans et donc
maintenant dans la deuxième année on va
en sortir plus vite que dans la ville
espagnole
parce que nous avons des vaccins mais il
faut encore c'est la mise en oeuvre en
bas qui va durer et ça c'est
malheureusement quelque chose qui
s'impose un peu à nous tous en espérant
que les variantes nous rattrape pas trop
vite
les calendriers déconfinement commencent
à tomber notamment celui d' emmanuel
macron il ya une réunion demain en ce
sens un emmanuel macron qui avait évoqué
la mi mai pour commencer a clairement
réouvrir la france alors qu'on va
bientôt franchir la barre malheureuse et
plus de cent mille morts dans notre pays
vous pensez que ce calendrier de
réouverture est tenable alors ils côté
c'est un des points sur lequel je dis
que le gouvernement prend des risques
parce qu'à force d'assaut vous savez de
parler de la sortie du tunnel
et puis malheureusement ne pas pouvoir
tenir le délai c'est extrêmement grave
savait ce qu'on raconte une blague en
russie qui est mignonne vous savez c'est
un jour elle signe qu'ils disaient
camarades on va sortir au je vois le
bout du tunnel
et il ya quelqu'un qui répond dans la
salle non camarade c'est l'autre mâle
qui vient d'en face a et donc ce qui est
clair c'est que il faut pas annoncer des
choses comme ça il lui fallut d'ailleurs
ce que je reproche au président mac on
sait qui parle trop trop longtemps il
faut s'en tenir à des messages
bref il ne faut pas créer d espoir qui
risquent de
pas être tenus parce que ça va lui
retomber dessus et il est clair qu'on va
en sortir mais il faut être très prudent
sur la date de sortie
merci beaucoup jacques myard maire a
l'air de maisons laffitte d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rtl france